l'académie de Versailles dans la
tourmente depuis plus d'une semaine
l'institution est visée par plusieurs
polémiques suite à des courriers
adressés aux parents d'enfants victimes
de harcèlement pour rappel une lettre de
réprobation avait été adressée à la
famille du collégien Nicolas menacé dans
son établissement le jeune de 15 ans
c'était suicidé le 5 septembre dernier à
Poissy les propos que vous avez tenus et
le comportement que vous avez eu en vert
des personnels de l'Éducation nationale
dont le professionnalisme et l'intégrité
n'avait pas être remise en cause de la
sorte sont inacceptables je les retrouve
de la façon la plus vive un autre
courrier similaire de l'Académie de
verset avait été envoyé au père d'une
fillette de 11 ans à Andrésy victime
d'attouchement sexuel par un animateur
périscolaire ce lundi 25 septembre le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse Gabriel Attal était au
rectorat pour faire le point sur cette
situation de crise un audit a été lancé
dans l'académie sur l'année scolaire
2022-2023 120 courriers dit de
réprobation ont été adressés
sur ces 120 courriers de réprobation qui
ont été adressés 55 d'entre eux semblent
poser question évidemment des travaux
vont se poursuivre pour
identifier ce qui a mené à l'envoi de
ses courriers en réponse le ministre des
taillé plusieurs mesures chaque académie
aura désormais davantage de moyens infa
d'engager du personnel dans la lutte
anti-harcèlement d'ici la fin de l'année
2023 pour gérer les situations les plus
rapidement possible et avec le plus
d'humanité possible la deuxième chose
c'est aussi un fait nouveau c'est que
désormais les académies les rectorats
seront évalués aussi sur la gestion des
situations de harcèlement au sein de
leur académie ce mercredi Gabriel Attal
est la première ministre Elisabeth borne
annonceront un plan dans la lutte contre
le harcèlement scolaire